previously on TV sins and we're gonna
have that HAP HAP happiest Christmas
since Bing Crosby tap dance with Danny
okay sure but can we talk about what
they're trying to do because not Jerry
seems to have you well in his grip and
able to kill you easily but is just
standing there waiting for this scene
that's just an excuse to justify a title
sequence clip to end why would this
facility as part of its infrastructure
have a button that remotely controls
this Ghostbusters style trap that Rick
had in his hand isn't that something he
just brought to the adventure you make a
request the meeseeks fulfills the
request and then it stops existence Rick
knowing about this meeseeks box makes so
many of his previous decisions in this
show completely unnecessary as
disposable as these beings are why
wouldn't he use them as at least an
extra pair of hands to complete all his
adventures with morning this meeseeks
dick is a brilliant way to play with the
beat careful what you wish for trope but
in a world where the genie allows you to
wish for infinite wishes God the show is
just the best this village is terribly
poor yet the giant that lives in the
clouds above has untold treasures Jeff
Bezos also this world not only happens
to have the Jack and the Beanstalk story
from our earth and it's reality but rnm
also just happened to land in the
village where he lives just a reminder
that even the most brilliant shows need
some little blue convenience pills once
in a while to keep their stories firmed
up mr. meeseeks was able to call an
assembly at summer school just to say
great things about her so that she'd be
popular and it looks like the entire
school is on board with a magical blue
whatsit they've never seen before in his
pro summer message also holy hell what
kind of acid trip was the designer of
this basketball court on the key area or
free-throw dick as it's more commonly
called
is completely out of proportion and
reaches almost a half court which would
be fine except the other half the court
appears to be more like a third of the
court and doesn't even seem to have any
markings Plus that far hoop which is
clearly not retracted and should be at
the standard ten feet has to be at least
20 feet off the ground based on the
scale of the bleachers underneath it and
speaking of those bleachers why are they
behind the podium when all the space in
front of the podium is available and how
did they even get them there it clearly
don't fold in so did they move this here
in one piece this is a gymnasium of lies
I know Jerry is a dim-witted sad sack
but wouldn't shaving two strokes off his
golf game suggests that he's somewhat
competent in golf if the guy can't even
hit the ball off the tee then isn't the
real request shave a thousand strokes
off his golf game why did they bring the
meeseeks box with them on the golf
course do they expect to need extra mr.
meeseeks during this tutorial but if the
meeseeks are aware of their own process
and abilities enough to call other
musics to help with what i ask them to
do wouldn't that impact their
perspective on their own purpose in a
way that negates my original request I
guess what I'm asking is how many sikhs
would have me seek seek if an EC could
seek me are Rick and Morty from a
spider-verse because I don't know how
you climb a mostly flat surface like
that without a little accidental
radioactive spider venom how does he
even know this I'm about to had it with
the discount Blue Man Group sexist
tential paradoxes here we are you know
walking down the courthouse steps why
would the courthouse steps lead all the
way down to the non giant world below
wouldn't the steps at the giant court
lead to other places where the Giants
regularly go also did everyone else in
the courts just stay inside was the Rick
and Morty trial the undercard or a much
more important trial why did Jerry bring
everybody back to the house for his
lesson how are you supposed to learn
this inside a living room was he trying
to hit a ball inside his house was he
just trying to swing the club because
I'm pretty sure he succeeded at the
second thing but what do I know
tennis confuses me what happened a bets
new hair she had a new style a minute
ago and now it looks like the old
[Music]
methods in tiring process look down
there looks like some kind of tavern or
something thirsty step I mean the 12th
step was sitting right there stop
waiting let this happen holy my
surrealist sci-fi comedy show just went
super dark the creators have even said
they wanted this scene to reflect the
trauma of assault and not be funny at
all but here's my question is this
really the place for I'm all for victim
sensitivity but seems to me the most
sensitive thing to do would be to not
unexpectedly reference real-life trauma
in a place where most wouldn't be
expecting to have to deal with it these
meeseeks are never given verbal
instructions we changed the rules so
that they can just Intuit what their
purpose is now we heard Jerry leave the
house when he told the meeseeks at this
point my golf swing is more your problem
than mine and he was wearing the green
golf shirt now he's in a suit but wait
neither Jerry nor Beth told the meeseeks
where they were going for dinner so
maybe after Jerry left he went upstairs
to get dressed and came back down told
the meeseeks where they were going but
why did he clear
we go outside after telling them that
there's only one door in the living room
that would open and close and it goes
outside slow rolls the stair folk Rick
rollin at this point I'm kind of
wondering how the thirsty step stays in
business but the location is awful
and most of its customers couldn't
possibly make it up here easily so we're
just saying hitting a tomato with a
metal shelving bar into a large pot
about 10 feet away is equivalent to
improving your golf game two strokes
well okay that's Jesus I didn't know the
meeseeks had such a huge arsenal did
they knock off a gun store on the way to
the restaurant or do the Smiths have a
hidden gun room and yet more proof that
the mean Sikhs get to decide when their
purpose has been fulfilled meaning they
could have bailed at any point and the
entire premise of this episode is null
and void and now that I've been this
much of a pedantic [ __ ] I can
disappear also the literal request was
to shave two strokes off his game and
Jerry got more than that by merely
learning how to drive the ball so go
your self stickler meeseeks your job is
technically done look we don't have a
perfect marriage but I'm not going
anywhere
define anywhere see you next week
everybody the fourth wall is my least
favorite wall yet them sad somehow every
time it gets broken the mysteries of the
heart confound us
and a boring game boring game it's like
watching flies I've dreamt a free
soloing account for 10 years and every
year it just looked too big you come to
fight us three men three men you are
what will you do without freedom buckle
up your your driver is a snail